[Music]
all right what's up mkbhd here and this
is the new iphone 12.
it's the purple one so this was probably
the quickest announcement at apple's
spring loaded event this april but yeah
here it is it's the same box as the
normal iphone but purple
and then inside it's the same
accessories or lack of accessories and
it's an iphone 12
but purple
[Music]
so there's been a lot of colorful
products coming out lately so apple just
unveiled at the same event their
colorful new imacs they've got the m1
chips and they've got seven different
colors now they've got colorful
keyboards and colorful mice and colorful
track pads so now there's a purple
iphone in the middle of the cycle again
so the classic six to eight months post
release new iphone color to get it back
in the news cycle to get people talking
about it again
and it works so typically this was a
product red iphone they've had a couple
red color ways drop six to eight months
after the newest model and product red
stuff was always this very deep vibrant
red and they were done in collaboration
with the red charity and helped create
donations supporting hiv and aids
treatment programs around the world so
why
purple this time
well i can put a couple clues together
first of all there already was a product
red iphone at launch time
second this might seem random but i was
told that purple was steve jobs favorite
color and actually i had to google it
and turns out if you google it
it still comes up that purple was steve
jobs favorite color and this actually
marks the 10th year since he passed in
2011 so this could be some sort of
tribute or a nice gesture
for that
seems nice now there are a lot of
pastels in the smartphone world right
now it seems pretty popular there's even
a couple other light purple phones this
iphone is kind of like a medium purple
it's definitely not super deep it's not
a bold purple at all it's more of a
lilac more subtle reminds me very much
of the xiaomi mi 11 which had a totally
different texture but same idea medium
purple you know what here you wanna know
the exact purple color i'll give you a
hex code
this
is the exact color google that pull it
up on your screen give or take how well
your screen is calibrated that is the
new color of this new april 2021 purple
iphone and holding it in person it very
much looks like this the aluminum rails
on the sides though are slightly darker
just slightly but overall it's a pretty
subtle look other than that
i mean it's an iphone 12 there's there's
also a purple iphone 12 mini so they'll
both look just like this no 12 pro or 12
pro max but everything else about this
phone is the same same cameras same
hardware same phone just purple so i can
see the comments already oh most people
put a case on their phones so who really
cares about a new color
but they're on top of this already
everybody's on top of this so apple also
made a new magsafe purple case it is uh
way darker way more purple but it's
launching alongside this iphone so you
can grab the purple case for your
current phone and it'll actually look
pretty nice i think it turns out the
purple case here on the red iphone 12
has this kind of cool double layered
look on the outside i think that's kind
of nice but at the end of the day if
you're after this purple pastel look on
any phone you can always just skin your
phone so channel sponsor dbrand has you
covered and honestly they're very close
in color minus the reflections so i'll
link it below if this purple really does
speak to you videos like this are pretty
short and simple some the question might
really be was this worth a whole video
and some would probably argue no
most i might even argue no but
at the end of the day when it comes down
to it people
care about new apple hardware and
specifically new colors of iphones more
than i ever thought when you look at the
view count of this video
i mean you're watching it now you got
this far
people actually care about this stuff so
at the end of the day this video
probably helps to pay for another better
future free video so that's a win this
type of mid-cycle refresh happens like
clockwork and if you're wondering why
i've already made an entire video on
this specific topic i'll link it below
just about why companies do this six
months later one new color of the same
phone thing and i did that video about
three years ago when oneplus came out
with a new red version of the oneplus 6
so this is not like some new phenomenon
so purple purple is new and cool but new
color six months later
we've seen it before so i'll link that
video below like button if you want to
check it out so that's it it's a short
one so you can go enjoy the rest of your
friday but even better we have a great
sponsor for this one all right now we
got a shout out to the sponsor of this
video skylum they make this pretty
incredible app called luminar ai and
it's an image editor
based heavily
on ai artificial intelligence and that
might sound pretty crazy at first
because it kind of is on the surface but
what that means practically speaking is
a whole lot of really huge time savers
and incredible functions just kind of
built right in with a single button
press so i've been messing around with
it a lot personally for instagram edits
recently it's kind of amazing for that
check out this photo at first glance it
looks pretty solid right but the
original photo unedited shot on my
iphone is this and this is a very
different photo and all the stuff the
sky replacement the re-lighting the
color adjustment all of this took me a
couple of clicks and maybe 60 seconds so
there's all kinds of tools you're
probably used to seeing in an image
editor color temperature exposure
sliders all that fun stuff then there's
things like sky ai which automatically
detects where the sky is if there's a
sky in your shot does all the masking
work for you as complicated as it is and
lets you drop in any of the skies you
want which you can then mess around with
with the sliders to make relighting and
filling in the gaps work perfectly i
happen to think sunset one looks pretty
good so that's what i had in my photo
and i think it came out pretty good look
it even added the part of the matching
clouds to the window of the car like
that is a sick before and after for a
quick minute or two instagram edit and
there's a bunch more creative ai based
tools that use 3d mapping technology
analyzing everything in your scene in
your photo to do as much work for you as
possible so look at how these sun rays
i'm adding not only match the light of
the scene but reacts to the objects in
the foreground versus the background or
in this photo the atmosphere ai lets me
add fog and sort of mess with the depth
of how it rolls down the mountain all
the way to the lake in the foreground
here let's play let's play a little game
right i'm gonna show you a photo that i
edited in under 30 seconds and you tell
me what you think about that photo is
edited versus original so this photo
from hawaii
yeah that wasn't the sky at all it
looked a lot more dramatic in my edit
than the original photo or how about
this photo from matterhorn
yeah pretty much everything absolutely
massive white balance adjustment
corrections since the pixel that took
this photo kind of turned everything
blue the sky the clouds i added over the
mountain plus a little film grain for
taste so that is really cool that is
super sick i'm glad i found it i'm glad
they reached out to sponsor this video
because i'm going to continue to use
this app for the future uh instagram
edits that i want to just get done
pretty quick like that i'll have a link
below if you want to check it out if you
use code mkbhd at checkout you'll save
15 bucks
you're welcome all right thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace